how's it going everybody is warned and
marvel has released some new official
posters for Avengers end game that give
us a great look at each individual
Avenger
last time they released posters last
week we got them for both the heroes who
were alive and the Fallen but this week
it focuses on the heroes who are still
remaining and it's really the first time
that we've gotten a detailed look at
each individual avenger outside of the
trailers some characters in these
posters look the same such as Thor Bruce
Banner Captain Marvel and her new
Avengers in game uniform that we've seen
before ant-man nebula and a Koyie but
some do have slight changes to their
outfits and armor Hawkeye has a new
uniform on rockin the long sleeves
almost looks like what he wore in
Avengers age of Ultron it almost looks
like a cross between Hawkeye and Ronan
we then at Black Widow who looks the
same for the most part but she has an
upgrade to her shoulder padding we then
have war machine whose armor has
definitely gotten an upgrade it looks a
lot bulkier and we know from leaks and
LEGO sets that have been released that
war machine will actually have a few
different armor suits and Avengers
in-game we then have our very first
up-close and personal look at Rocket
Raccoon wearing his original guardians
of the galaxy uniform from the comics
and then of course we get a great look
at Captain America wearing his scale
armor uniform you can see it in pretty
great detail here and he's also carrying
his shield and then of course we have
Iron Man in his new mark 85 Iron Man
suit which is modeled and designed after
his original Iron Man suit from the
comics as you can see it's a lot bulkier
as well mainly on the shoulders he has
the same arc reactor so we know this
suit is also nanotechnology but the most
interesting thing about these posters is
that there seems to be shattered glass
in the background of the images this
sort of reminds me of the mirror
dimension and as we saw in Avengers
infinity war at one point in time dr.
strange tried to put vanos in the
mirrored dimension it appeared as if
Thanos had defended himself by punching
through the mirror dimension that he
tried to place him in however why would
they put this sort of shattered glass in
the background of these posters one of
the biggest questions that everybody has
right now about dr. Strange's plan is
how could he see past his own death if
we learn from the ancient one in dr.
strange that you can't see past your own
death
so if dr. strange died from the snap and
turned to dust how could he see past his
own death to find out that the Avengers
defeat Thanos eventually perhaps the
mirror dimension could play some role in
avengers endgame but let me know what
you think about this theory and let me
know what you think about these new
posters for Avengers endgame let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and a reminder about my giveaway
currently giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet and some Avengers and
game art pieces if you'd like to
interfere a chance to win all you have
to do is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain and of course be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to Avengers
endgame and Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]